britney spears is feeling stronger
empowered and ready to take back her
life welcome to entertainment tonight
everyone so britney is free from her
13-year conservatorship now what well
apparently a lot the changes in her life
have already been dramatic and she is
i'm just grateful honestly for each day
and being able to have um the keys to my
car
and being able to be independent for
like a woman and um owning an atm card
seeing cash for the first time being
able to buy candles i'm grateful for
that brittany captioned her two-minute
video with the surprise tease quote i
might as well do a hint of my thoughts
before i go and set things square on
oprah really is oprah going to make it
happen i i hope so
right now there's nothing official but
this morning oprah's bestie gale was all
in the fact that brittany put that out
there says something he does something
he has more to say yes exactly right i
mean and we all want to hear the story
that's right
britney sat down with oprah once before
back in 2002 she had just turned 20 and
they talked about this coming-of-age
ballet
i can relate to this song to a certain
extent just me being at that stage in my
life where i'm coming into my own
almost two decades later brit and oprah
would have a lot to talk about i've been
in the conservatorship for 13 years it's
a really long time to be in a situation
you don't want to be in i deserve to
have the same rights as anybody does by
having a child a family
yesterday britney posted she was
thinking about having another baby and
she made some startling claims about her
family i lived with victims my whole
life as a child that's why i got out of
my house and i
worked for 20 years
quote i'm not even mentioning all the
bad things they did to me which they
should all be in jail for yes including
my church-going mother we think alike
it's really weird
britney says the conservatorship was her
mom's idea we sat down with lynn spears
in 2008 the same year the
conservatorship was granted when
brittany was hospitalized what got you
through that time like i say it's always
a constant prayer
does she ever talk to you about that
time and just say thank you mom or
we don't really talk about that time
over in new york i was with brittany's
superfan lady gaga who has been a vocal
advocate for britney's freedom posting
quote you never deserved what happened
loved that you gave britney spears the
shout out on instagram you talked to her
and now that she's more on her own i
don't like to speak about my private
relationships with people but what i
would say is this
i think that mental health should not be
used against anyone i care for her and i
wish her all the best and i'm so happy
that she gets to have the future that
she wants now
you